so much has happened about the Disney
Sony deal about spider-man it seems like
Sony and Disney are on their way to
working out a deal but in the meantime
we just have to hang tight and during
this whole thing everybody has been
pretty opinionated about things either
claiming that Sony is right or Disney is
right or that they should both just quit
it and get along how's it going
everybody it's Warren and we have heard
from many different people from Marvel
about what they think about this
situation and we've even heard from the
Russo brothers talking about how hard it
was to get spider-man in the MCU in the
first place but we didn't really get
their opinion on the whole situation
they just simply told us that it was
really hard to get spider-man in the MCU
but Kevin Feige managed to pull it off
however today they have given their
opinion on the sony disney deal and they
think that Sony is making a tragic
mistake so I'll break down everything
they said in this video quick reminder
tonight I'll announce to giveaway winner
for the 500,000 Xbox one or ps4 giveaway
and if you'd like a chance to win a
Nintendo switch be sure to subscribe to
my channel follow me on Twitter and
click the link in the description below
so in a recent interview with the Russo
brothers with the Toronto Sun they were
asked you helped bring spider-man into
the MCU in Captain America Civil War now
it looks like Tom Hollands wall-crawler
is no longer going to be a part of
Marvel's feature what do you make of the
split Anthony Russo replied it was so
difficult to get him into Civil War it
was an extremely long and hard process
but we were driven to make it happen but
Marvel Studios President Kevin Feige
pulled it off somehow Disney and all the
good people at Sony found a way to make
it work and it lasted a few films we had
a wonderful experience with that and I
think the audiences really appreciated
that marriage but we know how hard that
marriage was to make in the first place
so the fact that the marriage fell apart
isn't really that surprising to me and
Joe and then Joe stepped in and answered
it was a tenuous fraught union
throughout the whole process
but I will say stepping back and trying
to be objective as possible that I think
it's a tragic mistake on Sony's part to
think that they can replicate Kevin's
penchant for telling incredible stories
and the amazing success he has had over
the years I think it's a big mistake so
there you have it the Russo brothers the
ones who brought spider-man into the MCU
think that it would be a big mistake on
Sony's part
to keep spider-man for themselves and
take him out of the MCU and I think most
people would agree everybody really
really loves spider-man
but spider-man in the MCU Tom Holland
spider-man was simply a step above the
others and most people would agree that
it is because he was in the MCU that he
was attached to such great stories and
spider-man homecoming and spider-man far
from home were really great movies but
Disney and Marvel Studios were still
involved so a lot of people including
the Russo brothers now think that if
Sony takes back spider-man and Marvel
and Disney have no involvement that it's
going to be a big mistake on Sony's part
and bad news for spider-man but let me
know what you all think about this do
you think that Sony is making a huge
mistake if they decide to keep
spider-man 2 themselves and keep them in
the spider-verse that Sony has let me
know your thoughts in the comments down
below and again don't forget to like
this video subscribe to my channel
follow me on Twitter and click the link
in the description down below for your
chance to win a Nintendo switch and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof